[Music]
you're sure you want to run russia
you're a little slow on the strategy
front and yet you are abdicated
hey
i always forget the a a lot of season
two is catherine living out the
realities of a coup and what that really
means and seeing peter in a new way
because peter is not this tyrant leader
anymore
he's he's messed up massively
gentlemen your job is to keep peter in
his quarters he is your prisoner do you
understand that he's kind of thriving in
this new role that he's got all the
stuff that he didn't like of being an
emperor that was kind of forced upon him
the ruling side of it he's now free from
while you improve russia i shall improve
myself
violent lessons sounds awful and
learning kung fu
so you have unattainable ambitions
catherine's thinking taking power was
the hard bit but actually exercising
power is gonna turn out to be the hard
bit she's probably not the best boss
you've ever had did you actually just
free the surface i did you didn't want
to discuss it for us it was clear what
to do so i did it she's super young and
now has this entire country on her
shoulders where shall we start she's
discovering what it is to rule
back to work how difficult it is to
actually implement change
catherine is such a romantic and she has
this idealism and she was kind of this
fresh mind that came in if we are to
change this country we must change the
way people here think you could just
tell them what to do and shoot them if
they don't a lot of her ideas are
long-term ideas like they don't just
happen overnight and i think that's when
she maybe starts to see some of his
wisdom in terms of who he is what he's
trying to put upon the court tomorrow
morning assemble in the halls protesting
her rule scream for her to abdicate and
me to retake
this is my court and my rules sounds
perfectly logical
she's sort of not as in control as she
thought she was she has to appease
certain forces in within courts perhaps
i should have killed you but could not
ponder that keeping him alive is a
political gesture you are a terrible
leader what
she inspires you want to teach us
something and we need it
but maybe we can teach you something
they also believe in her but at times
she can be extremely frustrating because
she doesn't listen to anyone else so put
that in your arrogant crown i felt like
this season catherine in a way was
turning into peter
as a tyrant leader kind of
you think i will not last but that is
because you have never seen a ruler like
me before
because i am the future
[Music]